the top G Andrew Tate has been arrested
in Romania who is Andrew Tate I don't
really know I have watched some videos
from the man because my producers forced
me to
listen Michael we want your reaction to
this guy he's taken over the Internet he
became the most Googled man in the world
he's clearly pretty wealthy he claims to
be a trillionaire
I don't think he's really a trillionaire
but he claims to be wealthy
and he's gotten a lot of attention
because he says things that are
sometimes very right wing
uh he he I don't really think of him as
a conservative or a total right-winger
but he says certain things
they clearly upset the liberal
establishment and so he's been arrested
in Romania for sex trafficking and he
got arrested by the way right after he
got into a Twitter fight with Greta
thunberg
great I I think that was probably the
straw that broke the camel's back you
know forget sex trafficking forget tax
fraud forget whatever they're going to
throw at him you are not allowed to
criticize Saint Greta of the Blessed
sailboat if you do that you will be
destroyed by our liberal establishment
so he's he's arrested
the prosecutors have alleged that Andrew
Tate and his brother are suspects in an
organized crime ring that sexually
exploited at least six women who were
allegedly recruited housed and forced
into performing porn videos for sale
online
now I know that the
authorities are corrupt
and the system is set up to destroy
anybody who in any way criticizes the
liberal establishment and you can indict
a ham sandwich and all of that but
what was the guy doing in Romania
why did this guy he lived there okay why
did he move to Romania in recent years
which is kind of a corrupt country
that's known for sex trafficking and all
sorts of Nefarious activities well I get
that the authorities are corrupt and the
system is designed to destroy anybody
who questions a liberal establishment
and you're gonna die to him sandwich but
hasn't the guy admitted on camera many
many times to running and only fans
agency and to being a pimp to just put
it really bluntly hasn't isn't that a
lot of his career is actually bragging
about being a pimp and so he brags about
being a pimp and then he gets arrested
for being a pimp doesn't isn't that
I'm not
I understand that
the The Pimps and the hustlers and the
sex traffickers on the left they don't
get arrested
they they get to continue their criminal
activities for decades and decades
Jeffrey Epstein gets to live on his
Island and even after he is arrested he
gets a sweetheart deal at the Palm Beach
fake prison yeah I know I get I get I'm
not denying that there's some double
standard but
the guy's a pimp right is the guy a pimp
I don't know that's that's kind of what
it seemed like to me the story that
we're being told about the Andrew Tate
arrest is obviously silly part of the
story was that Andrew Tate gets into
this Twitter fight with Greta thunberg
where he's bragging about how he's got
all these cars and they spew all of this
terrible poison into the atmosphere and
then Greta responded in this kind of
childish way and then but then when
Andrew Tate released a response to that
he had a a takeout pizza box
and the authorities were able to locate
him by looking at at the address on the
take out pizza box and that was
obviously bogus that was that was
clearly uh a lie because we know that
the authorities have been tracking and
rotate if you if you seriously believe
that Andrew Tate has not been surveilled
by intelligence agencies for the past
many months then I've got a bridge in
Brooklyn to sell you this is the most
talked about guy in the world
he's got this kind of weird Shady
business life he's suddenly making lots
of money obviously the authorities knew
where this guy was and then the pizza
box thing was just the excuse to go in
and get him
uh is it is it fair that they went after
him when they don't prosecute their own
pimps and Hustlers and human traffickers
no but I said this in my very first
video that I did that when I had didn't
know anything about Andrew Tate and they
put the the clips of him in front of me
and they and I said well he's saying
many things that are at least somewhat
true some things that are entirely true
and he's he's clearly got the right his
heart is almost in the right place he's
trying for something he's questioning
the liberal establishment he's beginning
to Grapple with the fact that maybe God
does exist maybe there is a moral order
but I don't quite understand it yet but
the guy's a pimp and he's got to stop
pimping okay it's not
it is not based to live your life like a
street hustling degenerate okay it's not
it's not it's not based and conservative
and Trad and all of that to run and only
fans agency it's not based and tried and
conservative to be in your 30s and not
even looking to getting married
or looking to if you're not going to get
married looking to joining the
priesthood or or consecrating your
single Hood just it's but bragging about
how many women you sleep with and
driving your Bugattis around that's not
you play stupid games you're going to
win stupid prizes okay that's all I'm
saying if you go on air and you and you
question the liberal establishment and
you attack the powers that be and then
you brag about committing things that
committing actions that can be
prosecuted don't be surprised when you
get prosecuted okay
just a basic rule of politics
it's true that your enemies if they have
sufficient power can get you on anything
don't give them an opening okay not the
wisest thing to do but we're going to
get into the nitty-gritty of politics
right now that's on the member block you
do not want to miss it if you're not a
member click the link in the description
and join us
[Music]
foreign